your Carnival Cruise we just saw the the
big steak what's your take there Oh
cruise companies I mean I I don't have a
particular take on it except look I I'm
not a cruise person but like every time
there is any sort of you know you almost
know going onto a cruise ship you're
gonna get sick with something so if
there's gonna be a pandemic they're
gonna get you know even more sick it's a
it's a disaster I mean this is the worst
thing that could happen for a company
like them it's like amusement parks or
other tourist things except you know
when Disney decided to close they didn't
wrapped everybody inside a Thunder
Mountain for three weeks like they let
you leave it's awful look there is a
business there people love cruises I am
curious though you know when you talk
about how the economy will eventually
come back and what will open what won't
and you know you know you're where as
you said Yankees hat if the Yankees
announced in three weeks you know what
opening day we're gonna play a game how
many people show up at Yankee Stadium
that goes you know exponentially for a
cruise line yeah the the thing I saw was
the Saudis took an eight point two
percent stake in Carnival and it's very
interesting because you get almost that
the pricing conversation comes into play
right it's like has it bottomed has it
not you've got some people who've got a
ton of capital sitting around the table
and are they gonna get excited early or
they're timing it correctly and that
goes for the soft banks of the world the
Saudis except you're kind of all around
global I think I think everybody's
having to make a guess on when all of
this ends right because in theory if you
and I are still stuck in our house in
August it's entirely possible to say
that the Saudis state goes to nothing
and the company like they're you know
what do or care is act to great there
are only so many federal bailouts you
can do um and so that's the bet right
the bet is really a timing bet on the
virus as much to me as much as it is on
the companies and their trying time it
out and saying okay they might be able
to start you know putting ships out
again in you know make it up
August July September they're making
that calculation I assume the Saudis are
but everyone's just guessing nobody has
a clue
you're just making your best-case
scenario you're seeing this in state
governments you know budgeting
committees are saying well best-case
scenario stores reopened in July first
worst-case scenario they don't schools
come back schools don't come back yeah
the the ones that just caught my eye was
I think it's DC and Virginia both
announced stay at home orders till June
10th is kind of thicker
guidance and you know that's pretty far
away we're talking you know 70 plus days
away or so it's pretty far away but I
mean the the thing that would be worse
you could argue is if and this is why
Trump's whole you know we're gonna
reopen things by Easter which is this
weekend this Sunday which is just nuts
to think that he was saying that a week
ago is you know the worst thing that
would happen would be that everything
would start reopening people would go
out and then we'd all have to go back
into lockdown because the the crisis of
confidence from that would be
extraordinary one thing though is we
still don't really have any sort of
answers on how we're gonna reopen things
because we haven't done the kind of
contact tracing that has required that
was done in South Korea that was done in
Taiwan um it's unclear how we're going
to know when it is quote safe to go back
to work like you know I haven't gotten
sick yet maybe I have right maybe I was
asymptomatic but how is anyone going to
know how am I gonna know that is safe
for me to not get other people sick by
going into a store going to my kids
school any of that we haven't done any
of that stuff you know I I don't know
who I know or who I came into contact
with who has tested positive we don't
have enough testing to just test
everybody which would be the ideal thing
to do and then you could literally just
quarantine X percentage of people for 14
days to be done with it um we don't have
any of that in place yet we are so far
behind I I think June 10th is optimistic
yeah I don't think that June 10th
everyone's gonna just walk back out
their door and go do what they were
doing before right it's just a lot of
people saying hey the world we're going
back to is gonna look different right
whatever that ends up being but then
that leads to the conversation of how
many small businesses can actually
survive till June 10th without reven
Wright just it feels to me like we're
talking double-digit percentages of them
that don't come back after this
absolutely you know I was driving that
through Boston the other night and
obviously it's a weird city right now
because it's very very dark you know so
many it was like 8 p.m. so it's dark out
but so many restaurants storefronts and
stuff work yeah there were no lights on
and it occurred to me that when quote
the world comes back I'm gonna drive
through those same neighborhoods and
what I'm gonna see is I'm gonna see a
bunch of lights that are on but then a
weird number that are off instead of all
being off almost like it's 2:00 a.m.
it's gonna be 8 p.m. and a bunch will be
on but a ton are gonna be off you're
going to
see just just yet this weirdness it's
almost like when you're in a city that's
got like a bunch of abandoned buildings
it's going to be a bunch of abandoned
storefronts lots yeah yeah in New York
right now it's got to be 75 80 % in
storefronts or just off right there just
not operating at all and you know it's
bad when they've literally boarded up
like and I'm not talking about like the
Saks Fifth Avenue type stuff and I'm
talking about literally like the local
bar has boarded up their doors and they
just don't expect to come back for a
while and there's questions you know the
commercial landlords in this many of
whom are actually behaving pretty well I
am giving people deferments on rent or
even or even for giving rent but they're
paying they still have their mortgages
to pay and and so you could also a
building's go bankrupt you know in
theory when things come back it's
entirely possible that landlords are
gonna say you know to potentially new
tenants the new pizza shop we won't
charge you rent for the first three
months yeah they're gonna beg people to
come in because they're gonna have this
problem as well I think there's gonna be
a lot of Giveaways at the beginning but
somebody gets screwed somebody always
does yeah
do you think that if it is lasts long
enough we do see kind of the full
waterfall effect where you get the
businesses the investors are all you
know kind of turned upside down then you
do get the commercial real estate impact
all the way out to the banks and and
even could see some liquidity issues
with the banks so you were kind of
leaning to earlier I do I wish I didn't
I I see this is a really dark hole
I really do I see it and we're writing a
little bit about this the next couple
days as I said earlier the municipal and
local government side you know it's one
thing for quote Detroit to go bankrupt
or you know 40 years ago New York to go
bankrupt and you say okay this is a
poorly managed city a poorly managed
account to your town or they had a you
know an earthquake or something but
we'll deal with that because the state
can backstop it states not gonna let was
town or city go under but no state has
ever dealt with dozens of towns or
cities and counties going on during they
don't have the money to backstop them
all and and what happens then I do you
have to lay off all the teachers like
what the back-up plan for a school
system was about the plan for police and
fire departments or sanitation like this
thing to me yeah the the comparison to
the financial crisis in the financial
crisis we knew in retro it's started we
knew where the source of the problem was
we knew where the original crack of the
dam was so the job was plug the hole in
the dam and then go clean up all the
water that has flooded everywhere and
that wasn't easy but you
you could find it all in this case to be
honest in this case the dam has been
blown up there there are so many cracks
you can't even see the concrete anymore
and I I'm a bit apocalyptic about this I
don't quite see outside of a treatment
real soon or a vaccine real soon so
treatment more likely in vaccine best
case scenario vaccine is early next year
I I see this being it's not even a
domino effect it's a bunch of kids
playing Monopoly and one gets pissed off
and kicks over the table and the dog
eats some of the houses in the hotels
there's just not you know it just all
blown to hell